la nueva variante del cobi 19 sigue
propagándose por el mundo y por el
continente americano en chile las
autoridades sanitarias confirmaron el
positivo de una mujer chilena que
regresó al país el 22 de diciembre
procedente del reino unido aunque se
encuentra en buen estado de salud fue
trasladada a un hospital de forma
preventiva y tras la detección de este
caso las autoridades dictaminaron
medidas extraordinarias hemos decidido
que tomar una medida absolutamente
transitoria que a partir del día 31 de
diciembre todos los chilenos todos los
extranjeros residentes en chile y todos
los extranjeros que ingresen a nuestro
país deben mantener una cuarentena de 10
días también eeuu registró el primer
caso el gobernador de colorado
jared polis anunció que un hombre de 20
años ya se encuentra en aislamiento
preocupa que el joven no había viajado
recientemente
hoy hemos descubierto el primer caso en
colorado de la variante de 117 de 19 la
misma variante descubierta en el reino
unido- la salud y la seguridad de los
habitantes de colorado es nuestra máxima
prioridad y monitorearemos este caso así
como todos los indicadores de kobe 19
muy de cerca más de 20 naciones han
registrado en sus territorios esta nueva
variante del virus que se dice es hasta
un 70% más infeccioso y aunque han
surgido interrogantes sobre si esta
variante mutar a hasta un punto que
pueda resistirse a las vacunas las
farmacéuticas mostraron confianza en que
sus antídotos seguirán siendo eficaces